is open flipped closed this is the moto
razor haptic sounds I've been here now
for about three hours trying to make a
musical review with flip phone sounds
because the sound is awesome and it
brings me back to my younger years and
now here in 2020 the flip is back the
new $1500 moto razor and the thirteen
hundred and eighty dollar Samsung Galaxy
Z flip have classic clamshell designs so
I hired a music producer Ben Walden to
see if we could do a musical review with
just the sounds of flip phones can we do
it absolutely
he says huh you hear that creak yeah
yeah neither phone as is easy to open
with one hand as the original razor it
takes a little skill and muscle your
finger under there the razor is
definitely easier than the flip Z to
open with one hand though the Samsung Z
flip but the razor feels much flimsier
to flip because of its hinge you can
hear this as it opens and closes plus
you can see the screen rise up right
there and Bend don't you worry about
this as Motorola the sound is intrinsic
to the mechanical movement of the phone
razor has undergone rigorous durability
testing and the reported sounds in no
way affect the quality of the product
one sound you won't mind whoa
it's very satisfying even more than the
Z flip the Z flips hideaway hinge as
samsung calls it feels more solid here
anything
I can't hear so rigid and so sturdy now
for the foldable screens themselves this
is the Moto razor screen tapping the
Moto razor has a 6.2 inch foldable
polymer that is
plastic screen it feels very thin so you
can actually hear in some areas the
screen hitting the surface behind it
you can also seed outlines of what's
under there because it's plastic the
screen can also be easily dented or
scratched the Samsung Z flip on the
other hand has a six point seven inch
foldable screen with a layer of plastic
and a layer of glass house Samsung's
folding glass it won't say regardless
the screen feels a lot firmer than the
razor that said it still comes with a
whole bunch of warnings about how easily
the screen can be damaged there is this
crease here but Samsung's playing that
up creating software that splits the
screen in half look a mini laptop the
razor's outside screen is great though I
love keeping it close and just glancing
at notifications the Z flips outside
screen is just too tiny alright let's
hear it here comes the flip is back you
can hear this creak hear it and crinkle
nice I love it okay we're gonna move on
to the second section of the song which
I want to be about the why why would you
get a flip phone today
one word compact both phones are so much
smaller than a regular smartphone when
you fold them up and there's another
reason
remember when flip phones were actual
phones this feels more like a phone
phone and the call quality has been good
too why does nobody pick up the phone
anymore
and boom you can just hang up with a
flip big points for Motorola here it
also has this retro razor keypad with
sounds of the original razor what you
got so far let's check out why do you
need a flip anyway
phones are now too big I love section
two now section three needs to have
everything else that people want to know
about this bomb like the camera the
razor camera is bad not only does it
take bad pictures but the shutter so
slow you often miss your shot the
battery life's not good either it often
runs out before the end of the day
Samsung does that all better it's got
two better rear cameras that snap photos
instantly and it has bigger batteries
one in each segment of the phone samsung
only let me this phone for 24 hours
though which is not really enough time
for battery testing is there any way to
get in my like conclusion let me just
put this down any one second all right
let's hear it cameras so yes
the Z flip is the better choice of the
two but neither is as good as your
regular smartphone the technology is
getting better and better though you
could say the phone makers are just
starting to play the flip phone tune
[Music]
powered by ringtones by Samsung there's
all those levers out there tonight